Our thoughts are with the families
who've lost loved ones.
And we're also thinking and praying
for the people
who were injured in this attack.
Including our police officers.
So for an update on their condition,
I first would like to welcome Dr.
Jason Smith,
chief medical officer at U of L Health.
Dr.
Smith,
thank you, Mayor.
So from you,
though, health and you, the hospital,
I want to send my prayers
and thoughts out to all the families
that were affected yesterday.
Both those we treated and
and unfortunately, those we did not.
An update from us.
We still have four patients
in the hospital to remain in the ICU
Officer will still
officer will still remains
in critical condition.
But we have been able
to upgrade our other patient
in the ICU to stable condition.
The other two remain in the hospital
being treated for non-life
threatening injuries.
I want to thank my team again,
the emergency department,
physicians and nurses, my trauma
team of you, of our health
and all those who supported us yesterday.
I also want to send a
thank you to the American Red Cross.
We used 170 units of blood yesterday
to treat these victims
which far outstrips our hospital capacity
and their ability to get us
that blood to save those lives
helped save those lives.
So I want to thank them for that.
I won't get into too many specifics
about the patients
we're currently caring for.
We did operate on
three of them yesterday.
The required emergency operations
My team were absolute professionals.
We trained for this.
It's difficult to
it's very difficult to be able to process
what's going on during that time.
And so the training that we do
with our emergency department,
nurses and physicians,
our surgical services, our trauma teams,
the blood bank
all of that makes a huge difference
and being able to save those lives
because we have to act quickly.
But I'll be honest,
caring for three shooting victims
plus the other that came in
is not an unsafe, frequent day for us.
And the events surrounding
this made this obviously
much more difficult.
But to be honest with you,
we barely had to adjust our
operating room schedule
to be able to do this.
That's how frequent we are
having to deal with gun violence
in our community.
I'll tell you personally, I'm weary.
I've been in Louisville for 15 years,
all of it at University Hospital.
For 15 years,
I've cared for victims of violence
and gunshot wounds.
And people say, I'm tired,
but I'll be answer. It's more than tired.
I'm weary.
There's only so many times
you can walk into a room
and tell someone
they're not coming home tomorrow.
And it just breaks your heart
when you hear someone screaming
Mommy or daddy.
It just becomes too hard day in and day
out to be able to do that.
Now, my team is fantastic.
They're absolute professionals
and they're wonderful.
But sooner or later
it catches up to everybody.
You just can't keep doing
what we're doing
because you just can't
keep seeing these lives lost.
You can't keep seeing all the people
with these horrific injuries
coming through the door
without doing something
to try and help them.
And I don't know what the answers are.
I'm a doctor.
I don't know what the answers are.
But to everyone who helps make policy,
both at state, city, federal,
I would simply ask you to do something,
because doing nothing,
which is what we've been
doing, is not working.
We have to do something
because this is just getting out of hand
across our city
and across this great nation of ours.
Sorry, but you don't know
Peter.
Yeah.
So
he's still in the ICU.
He's still sedated.
And I again, I apologize.
I am not going to release
any other information
for the patients
that we're still taking care of.
Still in critical
still to save yesterday.
The next 24 hours are going to be
very intense.
Is that still the same set today?
Yes.
So he's still in critical condition
in ICU.
He's being treated
by our neurosurgery team,
being treated by our trauma team
at our anesthesia teams.
And is still undergoing
a lot of care at bedside.
Good news.
We had another patient released.
I know we talked a lot about the hurt
to see these people
receive
trauma care,
but the person was able to leave
and walk out of the hospital.
How does that feel
to see the good part of this today?
Yeah, so, I
mean, the answer is, is that, you know,
today we had for
we may have a three
the the ones that are doing
well are doing well.
And I think, you know, the work
that we do
with the physicians
and the nurses at the hospital
is just it's unbelievable
sometimes that people
that we're able to save these days,
we have partners
like the Red Cross
that can get us, you know,
170 units of blood
in a eight hour period of time.
It's just
the coordination of the city
of the health care system
and of the hospital is
is outstanding
to be able to say that those
patients are going home.